[Music]
i'm just going to start off by
by thanking all of you for being here
we've got a
panelist from four different time zones
and um it's really a pleasure to have
you here to have this discussion um and
thank you to all the attendees joining
us um they're all slowly coming in and
um
you know it's thursday night so
so thank you for all of you um for
coming so for those of you who don't
know me i'm tanya and i'm the co-founder
and education leader for aya
and since 2017 we've been working with
amazing digital artists the likes of jim
and angie who are here um to create
visual conversations around hot topics
such as internet safety sustainability
and the topic we're focusing on today
which is mental health
just to set a bit of context about
anxiety in children
even before the pandemics the stats are
quite alarming
one in five children has a mental health
disorder and as a parent myself i know
the importance of fostering open
conversations but it isn't always that
easy
and in fact teachers have told us that
they find it very difficult to broach
the subject with students
this session is focused on the power of
art and illustration to engage children
and adults in conversations and
education about topics like mental
health
and as a very
wide psychotherapist who hopefully is
here listening today she told me visuals
speak straight to the subconscious
so um i'm gonna
thank this amazing panel again
um and i'll be introducing them one by
one so we've got four different time
zones here
um so i'll go through these panelists so
amy amy herman is an author art
historian and lawyer and she's a creator
of the art of perception her book visual
intelligence really opened my eyes as to
how a questioning technique can be used
to make people observe interpret and
analyze a piece of art
she's worked with the likes of the fbi
and the military to help them get better
at their jobs by learning to see
um so welcome amy
jim
jim stoughton so otherwise known as jim
the illustrator
is a uk-based illustrator whose work has
been published in the likes of the
guardian and he frequently exhibits
around the world he's one of the
contributors to our anxiety issue and as
you'll see later
his illustration is so rich in anxiety
and yet i personally can't stop smiling
every time i look at it
welcome jim
um michelle harrell is director of
education at the north carolina museum
of arts she gave a wonderful ted talk
many years ago about visual literacy but
it's still so relevant today she's a
former art teacher and
today she explores how learning through
art can support social and emotional
learning
ein is an art teacher and one of our
early followers of aya and it's really
thanks to her that we saw the potential
of aya as an education tool and she's
contributed to many of our educational
toolkits
angie is a singapore-based illustrator
and she's also one of our regular
contributors she's the creator of the
wonderful illustration behind me
and her detailed works always connect
with kids and adults alike
and finally
steve lawler is my co-founder and
creative director of aya we've been
working together for the past 15 years
and he's really the one who introduced
me to visual communications and
publishing
uh this issue of aya is actually our
26th publication
um and it's actually the one with with
the most text
because we've used text as um triggers
and prompts throughout to aid with with
understanding the artworks
um and there's going to be a chance
after the each of the presenters to ask
questions so please do put them in the q
a and we'll address them at the end
so i will um hand over to to amy
well thank you very much tanya it's
really an honor to be here
and uh before i share my screen to show
some slides i just wanted to say that
the power of looking at art and visual
images i realized later in my career
really resonates with children and i've
adapted visual intelligence for young
adults in a book called smart
use your eyes to boost your brain and
we've adapted visual intelligence for
this new book for young adults that
basically it's a guide for adults three
goals how to see
how to think about what we see
and how to talk about what we see and so
when it comes to anxiety i think those
are three it's a good platform and
foundation to think about talking about
what it is that we observe so what i'm
going to do is share my screen
and just run through a very few
slides to talk about my methodology and
how it can be applied to thinking about
not only observing but how to we
articulate what it is that we observe
when it comes to anxiety in children and
mental health in general and my opening
slide seeing what matters is a painting
by the south african artist philip
barlow and if your instinct is to rub
your eyes to bring it into focus it's
doing its job uh it i think it's a
visual compelling visual reminder that
when it comes to mental health we have
to constantly bring the world into focus
because it's a it's a dynamic situation
it's an internal situation it's an
external situation we have to be able to
view all of our resources
as as a dynamic world and how we can uh
use them to improve a situation
because this is not a sustainable
situation this is what i call the deer
and the headlights and if i've learned
anything during the pandemic you can
find an image of anything on the
internet and a deer in the headlights
quite simply is not a sustainable
situation when we find out that there's
an issue we can't let it paralyze us we
have to think about looking at our
resources differently to begin to put
the pieces in place to solve the problem
and the first one believe it or not it
sounds counterintuitive is to pause
to stop to look and to listen
because if we run right into an issue
we're not able to formulate and
articulate to the best of our ability
what it is that we observe and if you
look at the slide that i've put up on
the screen
and you just take a few seconds to look
at it you realize very quickly the
horses are standing still and the water
is moving not the other way around
and as the journalist frank rooney wrote
about the power of a pause he said a
pause is when passions cool
civility gets oxygen and wisdom finds
its wings so the idea of pausing when we
have an issue when we're dealing with
anxiety is to stop look and listen and
take stock of the situation before
reaching out and and bringing in all
these resources
the second
uh concept that i wanted to introduce
was the idea of reconciling the big
picture and the small details sometimes
we get so mired on the small details
that we lose the big picture of what it
is that we're looking at and i'm showing
you the artwork of joanna vasconcellos
and she's a portuguese artist and i saw
this work of art and bilbao
and just to show you how human we are i
walked into the gallery and i was so
taken with her craftsmanship and her
artisanship but she made all those
mirrors and she crafted them that i
never stepped back to see that together
they make a venetian eye mask i just
never saw it so i want to remind all the
participants that when we're focusing on
an issue or a problem we need to step
back from it physically and literally to
remember the big picture so that we can
articulate our observations of the big
picture and the small details
and the third concept which is important
for all of us in all aspects of our
lives is the latin phrase festina lente
to make haste slowly and this 1872
painting by the biglan brothers
illustrates the idea that we all want to
cross the finish line we all want to
solve our problems we all want to offer
help but we need to do it in
synchronicity with others mental health
and children's anxiety is a very complex
issue and we can't do it alone and if we
just rush to the fastest solution we're
often going to have to start again so
biglin brothers their oars have to be in
synchronicity they have to communicate
with each other the whole length of the
race
it's not just about crossing the finish
line it's about doing it mindfully and
when it comes to children's anxiety and
mental health we have to pool our
resources and be in synchronicity with
experts to really address the problem in
a holistic way
and what i hope to do today just a very
short period of time before i take any
questions is i use art to enhance
observation perception and communication
skills but i'm also tailoring it to help
in my new book
to help with problem solving and this
work of art illustrates what i try to do
with my participants and readers this is
a barn in
southeastern michigan here in the states
and the owner was worried about it it
was becoming derelict and i want you to
think of it as a problem that we're
trying to address so she didn't know
about the future of the barn so she
called in a team of artists and
architects and they came in and the
project was called the secret sky
and what the architects did is they
removed a single acute angle from
foundation to roof to let light come in
in a different way they maintained the
structural integrity of the barn and
this was the result
and what's so interesting about the
project is not only did they consider
what the barn would look like in one
dimension they thought about it at
sunrise and sunset and inclement weather
and i think most ingeniously and again
applicable to thinking about anxiety and
children they put
solar powered panels on the interior of
the barn so at night one could see the
infrastructure and the interior of the
barn in a way that nobody else could
during the day
what i try to do with my clients and
participants is and i hope today what
you'll come away from this conference is
to cut a piece out of your evening just
cut a piece out to let light in in a
different way to put the issue of
children's anxiety in a different light
to not just think of it as a
one-dimensional issue but to be able to
engage all the many different resources
and change our perspective looking at it
from multiple vantage points
and again to illustrate this i show you
a work of giuseppe archimbolo 1597. it's
a lovely
black bowl with vegetables and nuts and
greens but the power of the painting is
revealed when you turn it upside down
and you see a head you see hats and
cheeks and eyes and a nose and what this
illustrates is what the late dr wayne
dyer said he said change the way you
look at things and the things you look
at
change
i'll say that again change the way you
look at things the things you look at
change so when it comes to anxiety and
mental health issues sometimes we have
to shift our assumptions and our biases
because the things we look at really
change and in a museum recently i saw a
wall text that just resonated and i
usually don't read wall texts no offense
michelle to anyone in museums but i
usually save the wall text till after i
look at the art but the wall tech said
how we look at things is fundamental to
what we see
so thinking about our mindset and how
we're looking at things is really
fundamental to what we see
and to show you that one small
initiative can make such a big
difference i show you the work of jorge
mendes blake he's a sculptor from mexico
who decided to build a wall all bricks
no mortar and he put a
paperback book underneath the wall and
you can see that the paperback book
disrupted the symmetry of the wall but
as you get to the outer edges of the
wall you don't see the book anymore but
when you look at the entire work of art
you see that one new idea one new
approach new one new way of thinking
about anxiety and the treatment of
mental health issues and children can
have a monumental and yet immeasurable
impact so we have to think of the idea
of changing how we see things and taking
changes in small digestible lights
one of the things i heard during the
pandemic that i want to include this
part of my talk with and then take any
questions is i heard in the last two
years well we're all in the same boat
the truth is we were never in the same
boat we all have different resources and
capabilities and situations no two
children no two cases are ever exactly
the same the truth is we were all in the
same storm
but that doesn't mean that we all have
the same resources capabilities
and and things available to us to treat
issues so as the storm begins to abate
we need to renew our situational
awareness figure out where we are and
recognize again that we are never in the
same boat we are still not in the same
boat and we need to be able to
articulate our situational awareness
where we are
to the best of our ability what the
issue is and begin to bring in the most
appropriate resources in the big picture
and the small details so i wanted to
give you an overview of how i use art to
broaden our vision enhance observation
perception and communication and begin
to solve problems from small problems to
really intractable dilemmas and that's
just a quick snapshot of my methodology
and again it's honored to be here and
i'd be happy to take any questions that
anybody has thank you so much amy um i
mean i it's uh for me particularly who's
read your books i really um
resonate with those aha moments i mean i
got those aha moments just from your
book so i imagine from your workshops
and and hopefully even from this short
share that other people will experience
that
um now i don't see any questions right
away so maybe i'll we we might wait
until the end uh but please to the to
the listeners please do put them in the
q a
um
uh and we'll yeah we'll we'll get them
to the minute but if there are any
whilst uh pandas speaking you may also
put it in the q a or raise your hand and
i have one thing tanya just asked
uh because there are no questions just
to take an extra 30 seconds
one of the biggest problems and i work
with a lot of mental health
professionals is that we rely on
pattern recognizing patterns and i think
when i use works of art to encourage
people to recognize patterns i have to
add a caveat because patterns can
establish biases and assumptions and i
just want to add the caveat that we
should never let pattern recognition
evolve into patterns of expectation just
because we've seen one case and you know
children no two children are ever the
same and no two children situations are
ever the same and so while we need to
articulate patterns that we see in art
and in mental health situations we have
to be very careful that
we don't let patterns of recognition
emerge or evolve into patterns of
expectation
got it thank you very much oh
let me just
um
actually amy said there are there are a
couple of questions right um
so this is uh this question is what are
the common problems encountered by
children
uh with with the arts
i
what i'm going to say is while i i i
don't um engage i i teach mostly adults
to use art for observation skills but i
was a museum educator for many years
and what children don't really have
inhibitions the way adults do
so
the biggest issue i faced with children
is getting them to articulate what they
see
and
separating the objective from the
subjective they'll tell you how they
feel about a certain painting and i
don't really think of this as a problem
but i try to teach children early on
there's a difference between saying what
you see and saying what you think
because later in life they have to
distinguish between the objective and
the subjective and when it comes to
mental health issues
that becomes a really wonderful
distinction so
using
art
to say to children well this is what how
this painting makes you feel but let's
start by telling me what you see and
then we go into telling me
uh
you know what you think about it what
you feel and this is applicable to music
and it's applicable to dance especially
you know in dance when children say well
i don't want to do that it makes me feel
silly well why does it make you feel
silly so you know how do we use the arts
to dismantle children's inhibitions and
i think the skills of getting them to
distinguish between what they see and
what they think are very important
yeah okay very nice thank you
and one more question
from um yock in singapore how do we get
parents to engage homeroom teachers and
peers to engage with their child going
through mental issues
once again i'm going to
put this in the bucket of observations
that the best way to engage people is to
enable them to use the resources they
have and the resources they all have one
resource that's common among everyone is
their sense of observation so to so to
say to a homeroom teacher my child is
suffering through you know a difficult
period with mental in you know issues
right now
uh this is what we've observed at home
and we'd appreciate if you could recount
to us your observations in the classroom
and so if the teacher is willing to to
engage with you
don't put more on their plate just say
you know we'd appreciate your
observations of a situation and that way
you're not burdening them but you're
alerting them to a situation and just
asking them to take an extra look to to
do the pause that i spoke about to think
about the big picture in the small
details and uh to engage with you that
way everyone has a sense of observation
fantastic thank you um okay there are
quite a few questions coming in um
some
um a teacher is asking um for signs of
um indications of anxiety or depression
now we're not going because they're
we're not mental health experts here
however that being said i did do an
interview with a a mental health expert
and uh we will put the link in the in
the chat function and she does talk
about what are the indications
so um so that that's you can watch the
video for that
um
um okay hello amy um if no if no two
children are facing the same problem how
should we prepare resources to help our
children
it's a very good question and it goes
back to my venetian mask picture about
the big picture and the small details
because the small details of each child
and the particular issues here she is
facing or they are facing are very
different but again to open the door to
productive dialogue and communication i
think is step one in any situation
whether it's with the mental health
experts or with the children or with the
teachers remove the inhibitions of
people just as we did now i'm not a
mental health expert i'm my expertise is
in art history and looking at works of
art so when you tell when you open up
the communication and say we're
interested in your observations we need
to prepare people to engage them should
a crisis or a situation arise but let's
lay the groundwork with everybody you
know do the best you can with the
resources that you have is what i always
say so that when a crisis does happen
and this is across the professional
spectrum you're prepared with your
resources you've laid the groundwork
this is my situation i have a class of
25 students
you know i've noticed this with 16 of
them i've noticed this with this and
sort of lay the groundwork when you have
the opportunity use the resources that
are available so that should a crisis
arise or different resources you've
opened up your channels of communication
using uh your observation and most
importantly your communication skills
thank you amy
um for so for a very different
perspective we're going to move on to to
jim the illustrator um so so who he's uh
from a creator perspective i would say
so james was what invited to illustrate
anxiety um and and i'm gonna hand over
to you now jim
okay
thanks very much so i'm
first thing to say is that i'm in the
staff room at the university of brighton
and uh i'm not the only person that uses
this room so there might be some sounds
in the background that aren't me which
is just the first thing to say
uh and i will now share my screen
okay
can you see that
so yes i'm um an illustrator uh uh
and i'm also kind of an artist and a
musician i do i do lots of different
things i'm also an educator so i teach
at the university of brighton on the
second year of the illustration ba here
and um i am a person that
suffers from um
anxiety and depression and
um
and a range of other things
that sort of get in the way of being an
uh
a normal person
um
or a
i can't remember what their what their
street slang for a normal person is now
but there is a word for it
it's like a normie or something
anyway i bought this jumper
from um a supermarket here in the uk
called marks and spencers
and they don't really do clothes they do
sandwiches and uh fruit and
smoothies and things like that but
occasionally they they sell quite fun
clothes and i bought this as an ironic
gesture i wear it all the time um it
feels like
an instruction
to have a bright state of mind or i
don't know if it's an instruction to
have a bright state of mind or to convey
to others that i'm currently
experiencing a bright state of mind
either way i just thought it was um
hilarious so i wear it all the time
and um
i am a quite sort of an impulsive
collector of uh imagery that um
inspires me or does something in my head
that excites me or
uh
says something to me or
um
it's usually
it's usually things that are
on the verge between
um
child like and
dream like and humorous and quite sort
of sinister and odd and disturbing
um
i just seem to be attracted to those
sorts of images i think because i just
find them
entertaining
and um
they uh they inform
my
work quite a lot so this is my
sketchbook i have a sketchbook that i
keep regularly um i have it on me all
the time it's here in fact um and
i
it's kind of a collection of
things that i'm thinking so there's
quite usually
i
write things that um
lyrics from songs or people things i
hear people say
or um
uh things i see written on uh
storefronts or
um
like there is an observation there that
says cut subcultural hematoma which is
my devastation at the fact that there's
no real subcultures anymore not in the
same way that there used to be
uh or there's a there's a there's a uh
a portrait of dr phil there
i find dr phil to be a fascinating human
being um this i mean all the things that
i see think here
uh sometimes i do little comic strips
that um
help me to understand what's
happening in my head
uh or sometimes i just um
sometimes it's like a a form of
meditation like a way of
distracting myself from uh
like a cyclical way of thinking about
certain problems or issues that i find
difficult to
overcome so my sketchbook is a form of
therapy basically
and then occasionally
my sketchbook um
informs other pieces of work so this was
a little animation that i made
uh in celebration of completing a
sketchbook which i do usually about once
a year finish a sketchbook and so
seems like a
an important part of my process to do
something with that but essentially
um
on my computer's doing the spinning
world of death
um my job is um
my job is kind of
stressful because it's so difficult to
predict it's so difficult to predict you
don't know if you're going to get work
and if you do you don't know what that
work is going to be so it can be quite
laborious and boring like the job that
i'm showing you now
where there's a whole process of going
through sketches because the person who
is commissioning you wants to know that
you're going to be able to do the job
properly before you've even started
um and then occasionally there's um
there's jobs that are
even more restrictive than that where
the the sketching process takes a really
long time and through the sketching
process you basically
uh
see the um
your
your raw the raw version of your idea
your creative vision you bet you see it
slowly get all the uh edges shaved off
of it until it's more palatable and
something that
uh lots of people will like instead of
just you know you
um so my job is there's a constant
difficult balance between
doing what other people are asking you
to do correctly and doing something that
you want to do and
that's why i
balance my
workload between commission projects
like the last image and personal
projects like this one where i made
a collection of songs and put together a
record and then did some promotional
material and uh
this is all promotional material now so
um
uh
it's difficult because
i'm constantly
trying to find ways to
do the work that i really want to do
that is quite
i don't really know what it's about or
why i want to do it or what it you know
sometimes it's difficult to even know
what the point of doing that work is but
it needs to be done because if i don't
do this work
um i become extremely depressed and then
the whole loop begins again so um
anxiety is a
source of fuel for me really i've
learned to
i've learned to
um
accept it as something that pushes me
forward
um
it's almost like a
a desperate fear to
a desperate fear of not
um
of not trying
to
visualize my thoughts and feelings as i
think them and feel them
um
and
without my anxiety i think i would well
i know i would probably do much less
work i might be a slightly or
maybe even much more happier person
i might i might be a very content person
um
if i didn't have my anxiety all my
depression
but i wouldn't do as much work
and
i'm not sure how happy i would be if i
didn't do as much work so that's a
conundrum too
um
how long have i been talking it feels
like i've been talking about 45 minutes
i've got time
yeah you're good
okay um
so well now it's just like going through
some some projects basically so it might
be best to stop here and take some
questions if there are any rather than
just keep showing you stuff that i've
made
but sometimes for no reason
so shall i can i stop there or should i
just keep going of course you can and um
i think later steve will share the work
that you did for for our for the anxiety
issue of ayah
um
i think thanks jen that was a really
honest and authentic and a share and
really um
really interesting perspective uh of
your anxiety um as a source of fuel i
thought that was really fantastic and i
imagine it's um it's really quite uh
well it's really quite inspiring um so
there's a few questions so
um kay is asking how
how do you declutter your mind and put
them into art
um
well
it's not really
so the implication there is that there
is this clutter that you systematically
um
tidy and that
unfortunately it doesn't work like that
at all
the clutter should be
so when i when i think of clutter i
think of like a desk with lots of stuff
on it it's more like a whirlwind that's
filled with cars and cows and jagged
pieces of metal and donuts and people
and and you basically just have to focus
on
one bit at a time and occasionally you
can
mix
bits up
which
so you can you know if you if like today
for example i was on the train and i was
thinking about um i was thinking about
money i was thinking about a song that
i'm writing i was thinking about my
parents as thinking about this the
summer like what am i gonna do for the
summer holidays all of this stuff and
what i ended up
drawing
was um uh the sun with a sad face
um kind of um
making a list so
the thing that the way that i
dismantled the clutter
was to just
get past all the responsibility of this
of the clutter onto this drawing of the
sun and let let him figure it out so
it's you have to like
you have to
you have to recognize that
there is clutter recognize that it's
stressful but then
you sort of have to um
take the importance away from it so that
you can react to it in a way that's
enjoyable if you can if you can figure
out a way to
react to whatever is going on in your
mind and make it fun
then the decluttering process doesn't
even seem like work it's just something
that you're
continuously constantly doing
thank you jim can you see the questions
the q a gym because i i thought maybe
you could um you can you can't see them
uh i can't imagine sharing
i can yeah how do you declutter your
mind you want to pick yeah do you want
to pick which one you want to answer
live and which ones you want to type um
i think it's probably better you do that
yeah i can probably answer them all if
i'm if i'm fast hi jim how long do you
take to complete one illustration
completely depends on the illustration
if it's something that i want to do
myself
i it can take as long as i want because
no one's asking me to do it
if there's someone asking me to do it
and i'm getting paid for it i'll do it
in the amount of time that they ask me
to do it in because if i don't i don't
get paid
next question hi jim
what are the main intentions of your art
pieces to the audience
oh that's a good question
um
well
i don't know if i think about that too
much
because if i did i think it would stress
me out to the point
of being um catatonic
i think i i think
it
behooves me to be self-involved and
selfish
unfortunately because if i think about
how people react to my work
then i start taking
their reactions and their
needs and their
uh their reactions they i start to take
it all into account and then i'm trying
to do things for other people
and um
that leads
nowhere good i don't think so i
i suppose the main thing that i want to
show is
a sense of fun
i said i liked i liked at the beginning
what you said tanya that
that my stuff makes you smile but you
can but it's full of anxiety i think i'm
i think i'm interested in
that that balance between like i said
before kind of child-like joy and uh
disturbing reality i think there's
crossovers all the time and i like to
put that into my work quite a lot
does your state of mind affect
the choice of colors in your work no
don't think so
it's usually
usually what affects my choice of colors
is what pens are in front of me i do
have rules and patterns and routines
when i'm coloring things in i like to
make sure that
no
that wherever there is a line between
one color and the next those two colors
should
uh be contrasting and jarring and they
shouldn't ever feel like they belong
together
hi jim are there times where anxiety and
depression gets in the way of creating
and what do you do in those situations
yes there are
um
what do i do in those situations what i
should do is stop and go and take a walk
and
get some fresh air what i tend to do
unfortunately is just power through
until i feel like i'm all right again
which makes my depression and anxiety
worse
um so i am in the process of learning
how to take a break when i feel like
things are starting to
fall apart slightly but that's a really
hard thing to do because what it feels
like is oh no there's a problem that
problem needs as much of my attention
and time and energy as i can possibly
give it otherwise it will never be fixed
that's what it currently feels like but
really what i've got to learn to do is
say oh no there's a problem now i need
to stop because i'm seeing problems
where there probably aren't any so
that's easier said than done
uh do you
do you know remember if you were anxious
as a child
is this something that you've only
realized as an adult was art always a
channel for your anxiety or did it
manifest in other forms of expressions
of child i don't remember being a child
at all thankfully
um but i'm pretty sure that it was there
i was
i was bullied i wasn't very popular i
spent a lot of time on my own
so i made a lot of art consequently
um
i don't think i knew that i was
experiencing anxiety or depression for
that matter
um but yeah i think it was definitely
there
hello jim what is one advice you would
give to anxious and perfectionist
teenagers who use art as an outlet but
at the same time
are super anxious about making mistakes
yeah
good question
um
so i would suggest to that teenager to
stop looking at social media and
instagram
because i think what most teenagers and
young people do these days is that they
are laboring under the misconception
that looking at instagram is a form of
inspiration and actually
it's more likely to be a form of um
crippling
it
you you're basically going to look at
the perfected work of people who
are doing what you want to do without
seeing the mistakes or the anxiety or
the depression that is definitely there
and that's the whole point of instagram
and social media to make your life look
perfect and effortless
so that's the first thing i would
suggest don't look at that anymore
don't look at
anything that is illustration related
really look to fine art or films or
listen to music read books
and
don't see mistakes as mistakes
the best thing that i
can suggest is if you do
if you are doing a drawing and it goes
wrong
turn that mistake into something that
you can color in black
that's what i do
mistakes are just like
forks in the road they're not dead ends
there's one more question sorry this is
going on quite a long time isn't it
there's a blurring of the boundaries
between healthy stress and unhealthy
anxiety is there
many people students seem to perceive of
any
of stress as anxiety mental health
issues how
do we differentiate help our students
differentiate between them
um
i don't know
i think the best thing to do is just
talk talk to them and see how they're
feeling and um
i mean everyone experiences stress and
anxiety i suppose at different levels
but
um
it just depends i think for me it just
depends how you um
how much time you spend focusing on it i
mean
the obvious thing that happens when
people are depressed and anxious is that
you have a tendency to slip into a
victim mentality quite quickly and i
think that that's always extremely
unhealthy and problematic so
um
[Music]
not um i'm not sure how important it is
to differentiate between the different
types of anxiety and depression they're
all
they're all problematic but you know
just see them
i mean
it's
if you're experiencing depression and
anxiety it's not like your life is over
essentially you you're just experiencing
an anxiety and depression so you've got
to figure out what to do with that i
i decided to use it otherwise the other
option would have been much less
productive
um thank you jim i'll just just to
quickly add to that um
i think uh the answer to that is also
education
and talking about mental health in the
classroom and um explaining to kids the
difference between stress anxiety
positive anxiety
um so that's something that we've we've
tried to do in our you know in our
educator kit so just to uh just to
finish that off so thank you jim that
was a really rich uh
rich and honest um discussion thank you
so much um i think it would be so
inspiring for for young kids to listen
to you talk
um so next we're going to go on to
michelle
who's director of education and she's
now in new orleans and she's at the
north carolina museum of art
thank you michelle
thank you i'm good good morning from the
east coast of uh the united states i'm
here in new orleans just for a short
trip but i'm normally
um in raleigh north carolina both on the
east coast
and
my background i want to actually take
i've
added even some slides and notes from
listening to our our last two speakers
i've really enjoyed it and i want to
follow jim's lead and share in just a
moment of my vulnerability is that
during the pandemic i found myself
having such high levels of anxiety i am
a former teacher but i have two sons
that are um teenage sons
and just my own um stress of managing
when they went remote at the beginning
of the pandemic and trying to
save jobs within my museum and just
manage everything
i found that i've probably been managing
some level of anxiety for most of my
life um
and now both my
some of my family and i are on
medications but i've also learned a lot
of strategies so
um i'm sharing some of this not only
from like that professional point of
view but i i can definitely see
the impact of this
um personally and i was talking to my
team so i managed the education team at
the north carolina museum of art um it
is a state-funded museum so it means
that we
are for the people it's free admission
and my mandate is to
increase access to this collection
across our state which is about a seven
hour drive from one end to the other i'm
excited to see in the audience that we
have at least one of our north carolina
educators that have joined us today beth
palmer um recognized a couple other
names as well
but one of the things um that we began
doing pretty early on in the pandemic
and even i want to take just a moment
too to something amy said about wall
labels and texts um and this is going to
allow me to
test the chat window for the next little
interactivity because as a teacher i
want to i want your input for for the um
activity that we're about to do is just
coming to museums and talking about art
sometimes can create a high level of
anxiety for people um my team was
talking about yesterday that talking
about art
with teachers to address anxiety in the
teacher workshops we've done has created
anxiety for them because they're so
worried about making mistakes so
um in the chat window if you don't mind
testing
this feature i would love to hear from
you
how would you rank your comfort level
when you come to a gallery or museum
does that idea relax you
or does it stress you out just a little
bit so it was with zero
being low and five being super high i'm
interested to see too
how the chat window works when we've got
a bunch of people
see
this is what i was expecting a nice
range
um
and just to address something amy said
do you feel comfortable looking at art
without going to that label first
i'll give you a second or two to think
of that
interesting
yes fives someone still
a museum educator yes
it's it's a learn skill when i see that
she's a museum educator i coming from
the classroom after 13 years teaching
art to middle and high school students
this was i
excelled in as a studio artist you know
connecting students in the process of
making art but
leading through an a student-led
inquiry-based discussion about a work of
art
especially a work of art that addresses
some challenging issues is was something
that i have learned a great deal in my
current position i didn't have as a
classroom teacher
and the last question is i generally
look at a work of art for less than 30
seconds before moving on there's been a
great deal of research about how much
time someone spends
with one work of art so do you
when when you go to a gallery or
any other place even the public art in
your environment
how often do you stop to really spend
more than 30 seconds with it
and
just discussing those answers could lead
us to hearing more about your background
and what
influenced your background to give you
comfort
or feelings of discomfort with that and
recognizing and acknowledging that for
your students this is so interesting to
me
because i
did not visit an art museum until i was
a college student and i grew up 30
minutes from the museum where i
currently work
when i taught middle and high school
students and brought my students on
field trips many of these students lived
walking distance in downtown raleigh
from great contemporary art galleries
and museums but they never felt
comfortable walking inside those spaces
so there's lots of barriers
that impact this level of comfort and
anxiety for students um
what i want to model with you today is
one of the strategies that we um
i developed this at the beginning we
have lots of strategies about talking
about art so i wanted to take a moment
from like um theory and and model
something where
for a minute you're going to be the
students and we're going to engage with
the work of art and i'm going to break
the third wall and we're going to unpack
this as if we were an educator and i um
i'm also going to time myself so that
that way i'm making sure that i don't go
over my time i get so excited talking to
um people about art so
i want you to take a minute or two with
this
work of art
and look closely as amy said pause
and take it in and i'm gonna give you a
minute to do that
and without knowing anything about this
work of art without me sharing context
about the artist process or historical
context we're going to talk about this
work of art using a strategy that i've
borrowed from the therapy world it's a
strategy that therapists use with
children
to help them develop mindfulness
one of the things when you're dealing
with anxiety is this idea of being
overwhelmed and being flooded with
emotions that you're unable to control
so
we're going to practice using something
that therapists call five four three two
one so you can write down five four
three two one or if you feel comfortable
since so many of you do we may even use
this in the chat window
so i'm going to ask for you to name
five things that you see in this picture
okay what are five things if you're
looking closely and i'll blow it up in
just a minute i just want to walk you
through the five four three two one
what are five things you can name
naming is important
and when you're talking about these
words of art naming is a great place to
start
four things that you can touch
if you
can imagine yourself in this setting
three things
that you could hear
if you were in this setting
two things that you could smell
and finally this is where i love to use
imagination with
kids looking at art what's one thing
that you could taste
i changed my work of art based on
tanya's suggestion
sometimes with words of art you get some
really interesting answers for what you
do yes
so i'm going to give you just another
second or two and we're going to blow
this up so you can look more closely
five things
that you can see
four things
and i mix up the order all the time as
long as you're consistent you're fine
five that you can see four that you
could hear three things that you could
what was it touch
two things that you could hear and then
taste
all right so i'm gonna i want to unpack
some of the things that are in the chat
window
um i see i see some really great
observations um
birds umbrellas hats chairs tables
um
shadows now someone said
if i was with a group of students we we
might unpack some of these things where
do you see some shadows
where do you see
look where
um a page turning oh you see somebody
here with a book that um
someone looks like that they may be
holding a book and turning in the action
of turning a page
someone would hear
wind and bugs so there's a lot of
contextual clues that are coming about
in this discussion
um and for me to only talk about a work
of art for four minutes is um
is is always a disservice but i want to
for the point of this break that third
wall and unpack this a little bit this
is a strategy that we've posted on our
website i actually have a video where
i'm walking through about five minutes
of this
and i've done this strategy with this
work of art
i first modeled it with some preschool
families
last year in the pandemic
and um came back to some of those
families several months later to ask
you know
has this had any impact did have y'all
did y'all ever use this strategy again
and one mother said that on a vacation
her son seven years old that was having
um
some level of anxiety was it was just
having a temper chant jump out at a
restaurant and just just having that
sense of flooding that we were talking
about and she used this strategy to help
him ground himself
in this moment of what he could see
around it so even though we're using i
believe my team believes that you can
use works of art to learn about anything
in the world and more about ourselves
here we're using it to model strategies
that can develop more mindfulness now
even though i borrowed this one from the
therapy field i believe that and i i
keep coming back to some of the many
things that amy said i feel that close
looking pausing
and taking that moment because
just with images if we think about how
often every day we are flooded with
visual images
that to take a moment and actually pause
and look and to unpack what we see
that's that is a skill that even if i
didn't share anything about this artist
who is um
an american impressionist spent time as
girvani but for this particular exercise
and many in your classroom that
information might not be important for
what you're teaching this might be a
warm-up that you do every day or
something else and if you come back to
this work of art later on in the year or
during another unit where you might be
exploring weather or something else then
they've had an anchor and they can make
those connections so
what i'm saying is that even the
strategies that you use when you're
talking with students to first um
and i want to go back to a question
asked i think to amy about
when you have so many students and every
student is different
how do you approach that um
by really
letting students lead that conversation
they're constructing their meaning
you can guide them especially with some
more difficult works of art of artists
that are expressing artists of color
that are expressing some um
their lived experiences with racism and
trauma sometimes i find that in i didn't
spend a lot of time doing it with you
but when i am
um modeling these strategies in a
gallery
i might paraphrase and and
bring out
some methods of like what in the image
makes you
say that just to go back to what amy was
talking about what you see and what you
think that sometimes they go to those
patterns
that they have in their head and we just
need to help them to well let's spend a
little bit more on this what evidence
this is unp this is why visual literacy
is so important because we're teaching
them literacy
through art we're teaching them literacy
through
an image and you can take the same idea
to any visual image photographs cartoons
primary text documents but we're getting
them to slow down and ground
their thoughts and their observations
so
um
what um um referenced earlier about um
mindfulness and everything our museum is
our approach to what we're doing is
heavily rooted in social emotional
learning and this is a framework
at least here in the states that we've
heard much more about um since the
pandemic and pandemic recovery
efforts have really focused on this and
this is um they're called castle they're
out of california the center for
academic and social emotional learning
they've been around for over 30 years
publishing research about educating to
the whole child
but now we're looking at just how
important that is to help students
to move past this point
that we find ourselves in history and
the particular strategies that i'm
talking about um
go into self-management
which is about like regulating your
emotions but we feel that you can use
works of art as a catalyst for
discussion for all of these different
things um and there's different
strategies that match up to help hit
that and just without getting into the
overwhelming details of it all this sort
of breaks out what each of those
um areas own castle's framework mean
um and again i don't represent castle
but this has been a huge influence as
far as our research recently in
addressing how we're thinking about
works of art um i'll include my link to
our education website in the um
chat window as well as my email address
and twitter handle and um i am very open
to answering questions
wow michelle that was a wonderful um
really
uh i mean that framework is uh it's
fantastic and um i i think all of us on
this panel i mean i know um iron as well
who's a teacher
um really relates to that to that uh
power of observation and learning to
look at art to uncover all those
benefits the social emotional learning
um you know so that was quite a powerful
framework and the questioning is
yeah i can imagine that it would be such
a fun thing to do in a classroom also to
hear the perspective from different
people i think that's why it was nice to
see in the chat you really different
people see different things
absolutely
and i think too
focusing on the discussion of the work
of art and and just that close looking
and guiding them through that that
there's several strategies that help do
that but the idea is
you don't have
i believe that everyone can learn about
art i am a lifelong learner and i'm
really interested in learning more um
about jim's work after after this
presentation but it's
you don't have to have the anxiety that
i don't know a lot about art to be able
to talk about works of art or that your
opinion is going to influence them if
it's something you know someone doesn't
like
works of art that trigger a lot of
emotions and dislike are some of the
most impactful works of art to discuss
with a group because that can uncover a
lot of thoughts and feelings as we're
really looking and talking about what it
is in that image that that sparked
something for me that i have such a
strong response for
um there's some really interesting
things to do from that yeah
um i tell you what i've got a question i
don't see anyone's got questions yet
that technique
that you used
um do you use the same technique on
different different works of art or do
you use different techniques the
questioning technique
yes so this particular
coping strategy
54321 it is probably one of
20 or 30 discussion strategies that we
have on our website that um and we have
a we actually also have online courses
for teachers we have um one for using
art for social emotional learning
strategies is about to start and one for
um
one for visual literacy that it models
many other strategies but this
particular one i find works best for
really um
vivid images that have sensory details
like i might not use this for a modern
abstract work of art i might find
something i see i think i wonder which
is very similar to something it's a
harvard project zero strategy that um
amy might have even been alluding to
earlier when she was talking about
seeing and thinking
but um i i feel like that this works
really great for landscapes especially
um there is one question um
how have your students usually responded
and what would you envision from the art
sessions and the intentions um
i
we have used a similar we've used this
five four three two one method we have
virtual field trips so
much like amy most of the
my audience i do work with students
directly at least once or twice a month
um but most of the audiences that i
engage with are adults and teachers
um
and and my team supporting my the team i
supervise so
we have seen in our virtual field trips
a really warm response to this
what i really feel like you have to
emphasize is how would you use this
in a regular setting how would you the
application of it so if you are
finding yourself in the middle of a test
to take a moment and stop
and and do five four three two one
yourself ground yourself take a moment
and breathe and then name five things
around you right now i see the ceiling a
light
refrigerator
you know and name these things and then
in the process of naming you're
literally aware of your environment and
grounding yourself in this moment rather
than all of those thoughts that like jim
said it's like a tornado it's swirling
through your head it's not just clutter
to unpack it's just like a storm that
comes at you so you're fighting the
storm to process
my next step where i am now
um so i've i feel that so far we've had
a really positive response and we've
been doing this now for about a year and
um
actually almost two years so with this
particular strategy
i'll put the um link for this in the
chat window and would be happy um i'll
continue to keep my eye on the
there is one more question um what are
the possible reasons
if people feel
uncomfortable going into an art museum
i'd love to turn that to the chat if
possible for those there were many
people that said they felt uncomfortable
why do you feel uncomfortable going to
an art museum um i'll share what i have
heard
i asked my family you know why we went
to museums
and they even gave me we didn't have art
in the schools um in rural north
carolina for many years so i didn't have
an art teacher until high school
and
art museums just seemed like a place
they didn't go it was a sort of a
elitist fancy place
that you needed to be within you know
maybe certain circles to be able to go
and feel comfortable there i know that
some of my students
from um
you know
inner city raleigh is a small city but
um they felt watched
and felt that people always they were
never able to relax from the moment they
walked in with the rules and the
security officers
so i think that um
i would be curious if some of the ones
that felt comfortable grew up
going to museums where that was
encouraged
or they were exposed to museums and
galleries at a young age with
teachers and field trips so i think that
some of this is just that discomfort
from what's unknown and some of it is
that many museums are not very welcoming
inclusive environments and many of us
are working to change that so um it's a
layered question
but yes
i hope i try to answer it thank you yeah
that's a great answer thank you michelle
and i think there's some interesting um
some interesting uh things especially
from the artists amongst the group so
michelle we're gonna move on thank you
so much um to to ein who's an art
teacher here in singapore
um so please
go ahead
okay let me just share my screen for a
bit
okey dokes so hi everyone my name is ayn
and i'm an art teacher so i've been
teaching in primary schools for about 10
years now
and my students make me feel both old
and young at the same time
okay so i'd like to thank tanya and i
are magazine for inviting me to be on
such an steam panel if i seem nervous
that's because i am
deep breath okay so for my sharing
tonight i'll be focusing on four ways
you can address anxiety in the art
classroom and these are activities that
i have tried with my own students and
they have transformed my classroom into
one that nurtures open empathetic
creative thinkers who have a joy for
learning and these activities can also
be easily transferred to other settings
like in an art museum or even at home
with your own kids okay so
um i'd like to start with a simple
exercise that i do with my students
every morning so part of their morning
routine is includes mindful breathing
where we focus on taking deep breath and
this is going back to what michelle was
thinking i was saying about um taking
that mindful moment so research has
shown there are
multiple benefits to mindful breathing
like reducing anxiety regulating our
nervous system and increasing focus so
mice i use this comic by a local
illustrator pixen
as it presents some serious information
in a fun and humorous way my students
love this comic so much because it's so
funny and i'm gonna zoom in so that we
can all look at it together and follow
the steps together so we're gonna do
mindful breathing
for the next
couple of minutes so let me sorry let me
zoom in a little bit okay
so let's try some diaphragmatic
breathing i love the second panel no i
mean the other way the breathing okay so
we're gonna
do some breathing right now because
sometimes we're so busy and stressed we
forget to take deep breaths
in the second row are you ready i have
been ready since you mentioned the word
breathing okay so we're gonna do this
step number one hand on your chest other
hand on your belly everyone inhale
through your nose
making sure the hand on your belly rises
more than the head on your chest
and we're going to slowly exhale through
your mouth
and you're going to press your lips like
a little fish
while exhaling and we're going to do
this
for maybe
30 seconds
okay
thank you everyone for participating in
the mindful breathing activity so now
that we're all calm and focused let's
talk about anxiety
okay so how about children's mental
health during this pandemic that's the
main question that i'm focusing on and
why is it important that we talk about
it now well schools have always been
stressful for most students but
especially during this pandemic
students are struggling to cope with
increasing stress anxiety and worry and
there's a recent article from the sydney
morning herald that highlighted the
pandemic staggering mental toll on young
australians and called it an urgent
national priority
so
let's take a look
and unpack what are children anxious
about and these are the answers from my
students when i ask them and they
basically fall into four categories
the pressure to succeed from exams
extracurricular activities or high
parental expectations uh relationship
issues with their families and friends
the prolonged pandemic where they are
uncertain of how the future will look
and especially especially social media
and i know jim mentioned something about
instagram not going on instagram or tik
tok because of this unrealistic
expectations of success or beauty
standards and perceived popularity that
social media has and that it affects the
kids so how can we engage children in
discussions about these issues that i've
listed here
in a fun and meaningful way while also
developing their creative and critical
thinking skills at the same time like
all the speakers before me who has been
mentioning we use art to talk about all
that so by using artworks illustration
other forms of visual media we spark
open honest conversations about the
children's experiences and emotions and
we need to equip children with the tools
to make them to help them make sense and
navigate the highly visual and
increasingly digital world that we live
in and that's where visual literacy
comes in
so
i'm tapping on to what amy said about
moving from objective to subjective and
how we look at art so this is
a thinking routine that i do in class to
develop my students visual literacy so
they do something called see thing
wonder i'm just going to zoom in so you
can see the kind of questions
that they have so this is based on
botero's bronze the bird
so the kind of questions that we ask
them as they are observing the artwork
critically and quietly what do you see
in the artwork what colors are used
what's happening so we focus on
what they see just on the surface and
then we move on to their own perceptions
their own
interpretations and questions that they
have
so um in the second column in the think
number two i like it because the bird is
cute like me
so very cute answer and she is very cute
the student
okay and in the wonder column um the
artworks make me the artwork makes me
feel happy because i like strange and
cool artwork so i love how um this
student is asserting what she likes and
she's sharing it with me all right so
i'm gonna move on to the second one
so
students observe this artwork with a
critical eye and they make thoughtful
observations based on visual clues and
they also are engaged more deeply and
they analyze more thoughtfully the
images that they are viewing so if you
take a look at the very last column here
at the wonder column and if you take a
while to read the student's reply
the questions in the column has
triggered an emotional response from the
student so it says i think it's very
difficult because you need to know how
to build it how many places you have as
in where you should place it the budget
and some people may dislike your artwork
and may say mean things to the artist
and you must have a lot of perseverance
which is one of our school values
okay so um with that in mind after i've
read that response you can then follow
up with an open-ended discussion either
one-on-one with the student or opening
it up to the class on their own personal
experiences where they have been hurt by
mean comments about their artworks from
their family members or from their
friends or classmates and then you can
also get them to share the ways to
overcome that hurt or anxiety of such
occurrences and how to stand up for
themselves
all right so another activity um that i
do with my students is an emotional
check-in which help them which helps
them to label and validate their
feelings and this activity also fosters
social emotional competencies such as
self-awareness and self-management like
what michelle was talking about again
using uh as a way to develop these sel
competencies is very very important
um so i get them to draw because it's
more fun and it's easier it's less
stressful for them to doodle and i use
this activity from um a game called
we're not really strangers where i set
the timer for a minute and they just
keep their pen on paper till the time
runs out not to overthink just to write
down whatever that they were feeling so
i'm gonna show you my students doodles
right now
so we have sleepy tired boy
my favorite is the one with the head on
the table and the chair
that is
funny and sad at the same time
so we also have positive emotions
excited for the new term because they're
learning something new in math or
because it's with
me the art teacher because this student
looks forward to art lesson
um we have mixed emotion where the
students are
confused they're both happy and sad or
okay but sad have to go back to school
and i love the one that's on the left as
well um it's
very very complicated and the student
has even included a legend at the bottom
that
clearly defines all the different
emotions that the student is feeling
and lastly anxiety as well like the one
on the right
the sweaty
stressed emoji that's feeling mild pain
because the holidays are over and being
worried about exams
all right last but not least i'm gonna
share with you um the one of
one of the best ways to address anxiety
in the classroom is to introduce a
diverse range of images whether they are
artworks books illustrations comics gifs
and you need to be intentional in
bringing in contemporary and
multicultural resources to deal with the
issues that the children care about for
example
let me zoom in you can go on to
instagram
to
show students artwork from the covid art
museum which is the world's first museum
for art made during this pandemic s um
covet 19 is one of the main reasons why
students are anxious about so showing
them the artworks the
the the things that people have created
from such a bad experience not only will
inspire them to create artworks of their
own but it will also make them feel more
connected to others during this
unprecedented times
okay or you can use illustrations from
magazines such as aya so this is one of
the activity pages um
when you want to talk about issues such
as social media like what you see online
is not everything there are fake news um
unrealistic beauty standards which will
affect um their self-esteem
self-confidence
or you can talk about um include picture
books like this one why do i feel like
this by shinsuke
yoshitake actually he's one of my
favorite book
illustrators and authors and i
frequently use his book
in my lessons in fact there's someone
else on this channel who's also a huge
fan hi anji i'm talking about chinsuke
i'd like to share with you my favorite
um page from this book because i love
how he has visualized bad feelings
so i'm gonna give you a moment to just
read these two pages
so his art is a little bit like what jim
was talking about a mix of childlike joy
and disturbing reality so we have all
this um we have our main character who's
having bad feelings cling on to this to
her body and if you look on the page on
the right there are different sizes
multiple ones as well clinging to
different parts of the body and it's
yoshitake is such a master of
thoughtfully introducing an abstract
idea in this case bad feelings and
requesting it in a very approachable
humorous way that that the students
enjoy
okay
so inspired by his bad feelings
creatures in his book so i got the
students to create um what they think
their bad feelings would look like
so i added an element of fun and
creativity and i wanted to generate
collaborative compositions so i
introduced a surrealist game called
exquisite course and it's a game where
each participant first takes turns to
draw on a sheet of paper and then they
fold it to conceal it and pass to the
next person and then that person will
continue and contribute and then you
pass it around until the drawing is
complete and the surprise and shock on
the students faces as they open to fill
the
um the completed work of how their bad
feelings creatures look like was
hilarious and unforgettable so i'm going
to show you a couple
over here
with
feeling very confused with the t-shirt
that says help
we have a couple ones that looks like
medusa
a mix of a pirate
and a cute one
when i asked the student um the head
looks like a dumpling and she said i was
thinking of dumplings because i was
hungry miss ayn
okay so to summarize my very short
sharing um the four ways that i've
shared with you of how you can introduce
and talk about anxiety in the classroom
is to establish a calm and conducive
classroom environment for learning first
that's the most important thing because
if you do not have this then everything
else will not be up um will not work
okay and you can do that by doing
mindful breathing next is using thinking
routines like seating window or like
what michelle shared about five 54321
which is amazing and i can't wait to
share it and do it in my class
that can engage students in open ended
discussions about the images that they
are viewing and how it makes them feel
next is to craft meaningful activities
that allow students to develop their
social emotional competencies for
example they're very very quick but
really powerful check in doodles that i
do at the start of every term and after
a long holiday
and last but not least to incorporate
fun and games jokes are really cool
students love jokes
right so you can share that with a
surrealist game or any other games that
you can think of okay so i have come to
the end of my sharing
if there are
any questions
and there's a question
um if you could perhaps take one
question and then um type the other ones
because um
my time management skills are a bit
lacking
um and we still have we still have angie
and steve's gonna go quite fast so is
that okay
yes that is perfectly fine i will do
that
so you can pick one if you want or you
could just type them it's up to you
okay um due to time i will probably type
all the questions that i have
thank you so much i mean no worries yes
angie
go for it
hi
oh man what an anxiety inducing way to
start my
presentation um i'll try to go as
quickly as i can
um and thank you to aya and tanya for
inviting me on this panel you know i'm
wondering what i'm doing here with all
these amazing people so i'm you know off
to a great start because i'm anxious
about my presentation so very on point
uh let me just
you know share my screen and then i'll
start my presentation
is it working
okay yes there you go
um
sorry my my computer died yesterday so
even better i'm using like a
a computer i
borrowed from a friend
so
hi i am angie and i'm an illustrator a
lot of my work
is commercial illustrations like the one
you see before you i am an occasional
educator and sometimes i
also teach or guest lecture in tertiary
institutions for youth aged around 17 to
20 but i also do workshops for adults
and younger children
in my personal time i occasionally do
deep dives and research into
intimidating and boring topics like
political history this work is done
during our local elections where i was
trying to educate the younger generation
about the political history of singapore
so this is five slides out of ten uh
trying to condense 57 years of our
parliamentary elections
uh so you know uh i like to do topics uh
that are like you know political history
the workings of parliament mental health
treatment in singapore etc so what i do
is i go through um what's on the right
side of this slide right like really
boring lots of words i crunch through
the data and then i present it in a way
that's easily digestible and visually
intuitive for people so you know people
can use it as a springboard into further
research if they choose to
so these are what i would call my public
service comics for topics i think that
people should
uh have more awareness about and i bring
this up because tanya mentioned that
there are quite a few educators in the
audience and in singapore um because of
the emphasis on academic results and
exams a lot of the anxiety that the
local children have are about you know
performance issues in their exams and
you know school and schooling so having
skills in visual literacy to me is not
just understanding what an image is
telling you
but it's also having the skills to use
them to tell a story or to teach a
subject
and to kind of aid children or you know
young people in lessening the stress and
anxiety of learning
so i really strongly believe in
harnessing the power of cute and i like
to use bright colors and cute characters
because they're usually associated with
fun and harmlessness to talk about
topics that are kind of serious boring
you know sometimes scary and
intimidating um
humor and cuteness uh are things that i
like to use
to you know break down barriers uh
especially when i'm discussing taboo
subjects um
so i'm often told by several people that
i trojan horse them into learning
because you know they think the
illustrations are really
simple and childish looking and then
they kind of learn about topics that
they didn't know that you're gonna learn
about you know so that's how i trick
people into learning stuff that i care
about and i want more people to care
about
um
so
this is the latest illustration i made
for is issue and anxiety um tanya told
me to draw stuff that kids were anxious
about but as i drew it it really became
more like a nightmare scenario of all
the things that i was anxious about
and the medium of art and illustration
often
references universal archetypes and
cultural signifiers and i love using
them in my work because as easter eggs
you know people can spot them they can
recognize them and then they you know
put their own meanings into my work
so those of us of a certain age might
recognize you know gulliver's travels
the the references to that um but not
the whole not all the younger generation
who are raised on you know classic tales
they might not like recognize it but i
think a lot of us would probably
understand the feeling of being tied
down and poked with you know sharp
objects by tiny little creatures
so other popular icons like the serpent
and the apple the clock the skull it
signifies death and decay you know your
endless notifications on what's up these
are all things we recognize and we do
like tend to associate certain emotions
and significance to them so
kind of indulge me for a minute while i
talk about my latest obsession which is
polly pocket and i think a lot of you uh
will recognize this character um i put a
few of these dolls in my illustration
and to me it's kind of like a symbol of
the pandemic because we're all stuck in
this like tiny little capsule uh we are
tiny little characters living our lives
in this super claustrophobic environment
you know and a giant hand is just
manipulating us playing with our lives
um but
um as i was sharing this on my instagram
right i was fangirling like a very young
follower
told me that she didn't recognize polly
pocket because
even though this brand is still
continuing to this day um
paulie is still living in a tiny box um
she went through like several style
evolutions from the 80s to
you know the 20 20s uh
so it's really important that you know
as we teach the young people what's come
before us we also continue to update
ourselves as time goes on especially in
this day and age of really quick
bombardment of information technology
and
change so you know remember to update
your visual literacy software if you're
someone who works with young people and
it's not really because you want them to
it's not just because you want them to
get your references
um this is a slide i used to teach a
workshop to a class of adolescent girls
um i was showing them like my comic
grades and my heroes and various ways of
making a comic um and i got very
lukewarm responses from them when i
showed them like you know uh charles
barcelotti who was like a hero of mine
you're like oh yeah he's cool
um and then i came to the next slide
this one
uh
sarah anderson is a very very popular
comic artist on social media the girls
immediately started screaming and going
like oh my god i follow her on instagram
she's awesome you know that comic she
did blah blah blah
and that broke the eyes in a way that
the other you know people that i showed
couldn't
and you know i think it's it's because
uh it showed them that i was connected
to them
um and you know i always knew that
connection with your students or your
kids is very important but i've never
experienced it so viscerally until i was
in a room of you know streaming teenage
girls that was really really great
um
but apart from establishing a connection
i think the
most important thing
when you talk to youth about anxiety or
mental health issues is to not pretend
that you've got everything together it's
very tempting as an adult
to pretend that you know you you know
what you're doing
especially in front of younger people
but it's kind of like a lie so um i do a
lot of comics about my own anxieties my
depression occasional suicidal thoughts
um and so what happened after i
published them was that a lot of my
students felt you know that they were
able to talk to me very frankly about
what they were feeling
right because i stopped being like a
authority figure to them i was also a
human being who goes through like
negative sometimes depressive emotions
like they do
and you know they felt like hey you get
me i can talk to you about this
um so the last point i want to make
is that you know
one way to not the last point second
last point that i want to make is to
uh use memes or comics or tik tok videos
you know if you're not a creator
yourself there's already a lot of
resources out there that you can use to
springboard and start the conversation
uh because i honestly i think a lot of
the the kids these days and the youth
are a lot uh they have way higher visual
literacy than adults because they grew
up in an
environment where everything is so
visual you know like they've got
instagram they've got tumblr
tick tock whatever
so we should we should be leveraging on
this
um to you know start talking about
anxiety and
um i think the last point i want to make
is about allowing for ambiguity when you
talk about mental health issues
there isn't a single way to interpret a
drawing or painting of photographs and
they there can be many
small narratives within a larger
narrative so you know who cares what the
artist means you know who cares about
the artist statement um because when you
look at the picture you can you can read
the statement and be like i don't think
that's that's what it means right and i
think michelle kind of talked about it a
little bit in her presentation
um you know because once like as a
person who creates you know once i put
my artwork out in the world i don't have
control over what people think about it
and i'm okay with that you know in fact
i hate explaining my work because then
it limits what people might think about
it so um
[Music]
very importantly uh don't put your own
narratives onto their narratives
um allow the students to tell their own
stories give them the space to to say it
even if it makes you really
uncomfortable even if it makes you
feel like you don't know how to respond
i mean i've had experiences where my my
students tell me that you know
they commit like they attempted suicide
i see the marks on their skin i see like
you know marked on their necks i've had
two students in one semester like
attempt suicide and then i had to talk
to them afterwards um and i you know i
was scrambling i didn't have any
training i didn't know what to say or
what to do
um but i think
that's okay you know you don't need to
have all the answers um but i do think
you need to kind of
be able to reserve judgment and hold
space
for
you know your kids
so anyways that's the end of my
presentation i hope uh it made some
sense and thank you for listening uh
yeah
thank you so much angie i think a few
people were disturbed they couldn't see
your face during the presentation
so
we look forward i think they just want
to see your nice smile
so thank you angie that was um really
really lovely
hi so
hi
welcome back
so um angie if you don't mind answering
the questions in the
in the q a
um hold on because i'm just conscious of
time
yep
should i type it out
or yeah if they come if questions come
okay um because i just want to give
steve a quick very quick share and then
i will uh kind of wrap up for everyone
um so steve please go ahead and and
sorry to everyone for my bad time
management
are you still awake steve
yeah i'm still here don't worry and also
we're not that late so it's okay i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna bring up like
the um
our latest what we've put together for
anxiety and and kind of touch on some of
the things everybody spoke about um
there's been a big focus on art and i
think maybe some concerns in the
in the audience about
a reliance on ability of art and things
like that perhaps like
uh teachers feel like they're not
equipped
to to talk about it or
uh things like that like they're not
informed enough about this subject of
art to be an authority but i think
what what we're trying to do here is um
is just talk about the idea like you
know the 54321 was a great example
because you don't need to be an
authority on art to kind of break down a
break down an artwork um
sorry i want to start on a different
slide i want to start here
um and what i think what we want to do
with anger as well is not sort of um
trying to get everyone to become artists
but to get everybody to think creatively
and i think the using illustrations and
art is is just the best way of
demonstrating
uh how people look at the world
differently um and and like uh angie
said you know what does that what the
artist intended perhaps is not important
because everybody has their own sort of
different sets of interpretations when
they when they come to a piece but but
what what we extract from all that is
this idea of um
there's no right answer and i think once
you remove this
need to have a right answer it
alleviates a lot of the pressure and
perhaps a lot of the anxiety in the
classroom so so creating kind of
activities where
there's no right answer like a bad ideas
session okay everybody let's think of
something wild and crazy outside the
bounds of reality i think this is where
um
children excel
and you know if they don't then we need
to nurture that and i think what tends
to happen in school is as they get older
they're less and less encouraged to kind
of free think and um
and to add their and the world's
detriment to be honest um because
problem solving is literally always
about looking at things in a new
perspective and i think that's what we
try to do um we want you to explore
um
different thoughts we want you to look
we want you to observe and observations
a word i'm really happy has kind of
reappeared throughout tonight in
different in different contexts and
being observant is a really sort of key
skill in life uh whether you're going to
be a policeman or a woman uh you know
dentist or whatever being observant is
key
um
in regards to anxiety we've got a load
of different subjects to cover uh we
offered like in the in the magazine we
have there's gyms we've got gyms as a
coloring in as a sort of a little art
therapy that people will be able to to
go through
um
we've got these sort of coping
mechanisms uh you know i think it's
standard that we should have this in
there but we're not trying to preach
we're just sort of offering little
tidbits and and kind of activities and
thoughts
that can
um guide people through a discussion
about anxiety
so for example this artwork is by look
look in singapore um when negative
thoughts start re repeating uh you know
and so if you start hyper focusing on
something then try and think of
something else try and shift your
attention to something else and and that
method of distraction
um
is it is a tool that that is used and
also
this is a nice way of bringing it to the
surface to talk to your students about
it um
we've got like things like social media
which came up tonight
more in regards to
finished works and the perfect edit and
i think this idea of
stop uh trying to be like strangers
online you know unfollow the unfollow
um
people that make you unhappy you know um
unhealthy expectations
these types of ideas the they're
relevant to the to the youngsters but
they're also sort of like they're very
poignant to everybody um
but i think having these visual
these illustrations are really
charming and inviting and then of course
you start to you start to unravel them
and start to discuss some of the things
that
that are involved and of course we make
these worksheets which is a kind of two
teachers toolkit to accompany the
magazine um
which you know kind of go a lot deeper
but i think just to the average kind of
uh
reader of this magazine they're gonna
respond and relate to a lot of the
imagery in here uh angie you mentioned
memes um
you know this idea when the teacher is
looking around the classroom for one of
us to answer i think the language of
memes is so important um spoken to young
people and of course
because it's so disposable and humorous
and things like that i feel like it does
open little doorways into conversations
um you know you can ask the kids to go
and find a meme which how do they feel
you know a meme which reflects their
mood and it becomes a kind of tool of
expression for them
um
we've got these lovely uh illustrations
you know and they're accompanied by not
facts but
little snippets of of of information so
life can get a little hectic the time to
relax is when you don't have time for it
and you know just trying to get these
little sound bites and these little
nuggets
um it's quite a profound idea but you
know you hopefully this image drives it
home like it kind of sends
the message deeper
um
and we are visual people you know i mean
we we we look at things we see this is a
maze we see the chaos we try and
dial in on things that we relate to and
and hopefully
the outtake is that we're not alone you
know like uh you're not alone and um and
there's kind of shared
um emotions and things i mean jim i'm
gonna show your work now
um
one thing we like to ask the kids is
what are you afraid of and what's your
most ridiculous fear um we're all afraid
of strange things
i love this egg um looking at his
existential fried egg future um
and i i just sort of pulled that out
because it preempts what you're about to
see which is this uh
full assault on the eyes and the brain
of
um
where do you look first you know i mean
okay that like tanya said there's an
anxiety inherent in the work but also
just when you start to go in and you
start to
sort of sense you see the humor but also
the sort of undertone of actual fears
and um there's just a lot going on here
and i think
screenshot this if you can or you know
um
or or go to jim's website or instagram
and just you know
there's so much in there it's so hard to
just look at this for
a few seconds and really extract
everything out of it but um
you know what am i doing you know the
man underneath the shoe
uh i'm covered up by the thumbnail sorry
on my own screen wait um
the guy going to get plugged in
this worm melting on the on the light
bulb i mean
there's just a lot going on and it's
amazing and i think
and angie's artwork which she just
showed as well
um peppered with pop culture references
and
and kind of uh
psle is the exams in singapore
um i've got a 10 year old and he
a 10 year old boy and he looked at this
image and he was just like oh i know
this there's there's there's like uh
um
what's it called that korean show i've
forgotten already the uh not the hunger
game something like that and he
recognized them all and i think when
you're when you're using the language
that they understand
then the message becomes really
effective um
and so yeah i think just in terms of um
this is a little sneaky peaky of the
issue this is coming out we're getting
them on friday uh we're having an
exhibition to launch the um issue next
friday up at cop cafe
and you can come up and grab an issue if
you're in singapore if not they're on
our website as physical and ebooks
and i think tanya um
if i've missed anything let me know no
um i'm gonna wrap up now
yeah
that's all yeah
yeah i think uh that was
it was um
a really uh brilliant session i'm um
thank you to those who stayed on thank
you especially to all of you the
panelists
um uh i have to thank design singapore
council because it's thanks to them
we've been able to do this and make it
available for free to to all teachers in
singapore so um thank you and i really
just want to wrap up by saying i think
for me this session was so rich because
of the variety of perspectives even
though no one here is actually a mental
health professional i think we're from a
creative industry where either creators
or or we work within within the arts and
in education and in museums and i think
what this shows is by bringing together
people from different
backgrounds that we can start to create
connections and have conversations and i
hope this has opened the eyes or been
inspiring for people from mental health
but also from people in education and we
can start to connect the dots and solve
some of these problems like like amy
referred to at the beginning
so um
yeah
thank you thank you everybody uh thank
you all the the smds for for staying
late
and
to all your amazing panelists
thank you
and and good good morning and good
evening
pleasure
thanks for having me
and good night bye